I want to continue a bit about data
mining but maybe from a way that you
haven't thought about data mining before
so data mining mean a huge amount of
data we you know fair enough lots of
number crunching that's that's good
that's difficult but one thing but
actually a lot of our work these days is
what I would call more than modeling
side of things where you need to do data
mining but you need to do it a bit
differently and here's a really good
example of something we worked on on
something you probably familiar with so
this is Khalid over the border crossing
where the UK Border Agency and the UK
border force or try and prevent people
to illegally cross in particular we're
talking about people who are hiding on
lorries so the color and Dover crossing
is actually the main crossing from the
UK into Europe where all the lorry and
car traffic goes through every year more
than a million lorry goes through there
are many million cars it's almost like a
motorway really but obviously there's to
see in the middle it's also one of the
main entry points for illegal
immigration into UK where people are
trying to hide on lorries trying to get
across without the right papers we've
had the right visa and so on they do
this by usually at night climbing onto
the lorries highly between the pallets
of goods between hiding between water
bottles or whatever they can find and
it's the UK border forces job to try and
find people hiding there so they
actually operate on French soil to get a
whiff to French police in the French
port authorities briefly a map of the
poor just give an idea so you know
lorries will come in here sort of snake
through there and they go to passport
control and it'll go through some French
controls and then they come to ticketing
system that come to the British controls
where again the neatest row passports
and eventually there's more controls by
the British and then you finally park
and go on to the ferries so on the
French side you have a number of
technologies that are being used
something called passive millimeter-wave
best showing a picture really that's
probably the easiest
look something like this so a lorry will
slowly drive through here and cosmic
rays will deflect off that screen into
this container don't want to say number
one on and what do you get from that is
something a bit like a low-level x-ray
picture and you can kind of make out
shapes in the lorry and that obviously
if somebody is sitting there or standing
there you can probably see some
but this doesn't always work because if
the lorry has hard sides that the Rays
aren't really strong enough and also if
two people are hiding really well and
you can't really see them so other
technologies that are being used is this
one called a heartbeat detector it can't
literally detect a heartbeat but it's
really really sensitive so you attach it
to three points of the lorry the front
the middle and the back and you
basically just see if the lorry is
shaking ever so slightly which it would
do if there's somebody on there moving
and yes oh the driver forgot to switch
the radio or for somebody slamming the
car door or it's not perfectly theology
or you've got this one here which is the
something called the co2 probe which has
got off like a ski stick attached to you
poke the stick into the lorry if you
find somebody you know but if you don't
then you can suck up some air and from
there you can see what's the proportion
of oxygen to carbon dioxide carbon
monoxide these sort of things and you
can compare it to the outside air and if
the proportions are the same then
probably nobody's breathing on the lorry
but if the proportions are different
then maybe somebody's breathing on the
lorry or maybe the lorries transporting
paper or trees or goods which produce
oxygen and again it's not perfect also
you've got some dogs which are quite
good but at higher very easily none of
them is perfect and the reason we've
been working with the UK Border Agency
is because they asked us okay so we can
give you lots of data and give you a
whole years worth of data of what we've
checked and what we found how can we
improve our process how can we find more
people with the same resources do we
need more resources you know what should
we do so it sounded like it's a classic
data mining problem unfortunately
there's a big big problem here which is
what they're really after is something
which is unknown we don't know how many
people are hiding and we also don't know
how many people are getting through all
they know is how many people we are
finding so if you try and optimize this
system and you're trying to say okay if
you put more checks in the less people
get through but you don't know because
you obviously don't know how many go
through the first placing the only way
how get through now so you can't do your
classic data mining on this one because
it it's unknown you never know how many
people are going to hide you never know
how people are getting through you only
know how many people you're finding so
you're finding more people that's that
mean you're doing a better job maybe
it's just more people hiding what we do
for something like this is we build a
magical model of the port
will lead onto assimilations this is
perhaps a surprise to some people so
data mining could mean number crunching
but it can also mean something like a
simulation of the system because we
actually need to understand what's going
on if you understand what's going on
then we can optimize it so to understand
something like this what we build is a
computer simulation which first of all
means we may have to make a more
abstract model of it so we have like
how's the flowed through the port
exactly what are the different stages
what is the probability you go from here
to here
how many lorries exactly are branching
there how many have hard sides how many
have soft sides how many go into this
check and so on it's on lots of lots of
things like this and from this we can
build up a simulation of it so you
recognize this is the map of the port
you got lorries coming in as they would
in real life and they go through
different checks here they go to a
passport check I go through a heartbeat
check they go to purses millimeter-wave
ticketing and they also go through the
UK where they would go to different
shirts and we can look at these lorries
in great detail yellow lorries means
that there's nobody on board red lorries
would mean there's actually somebody
hiding and we can follow the lorries
here and we can check ok if there's
somebody hiding where is he being found
other being found where they're not
being found and what's underlying this
sort of more pretty simulation is
actually a more abstract computer
science simulation which looks something
like this you've got a logical flow
through the system you can see exactly
at each moment in time which of these
stations is busy where is the lorry
right now who's working on the lowly
who's checking it and I've got all total
parameters here I can change how many
lorries researching how many people are
hiding I can change how many have soft
and hard sides all the sort of important
parameters in the system and from this I
can then generate lots of output again
which is like given this scenario this
is the output given that's in our
olicity output and then I can do my data
mining and all these different outputs
and from there I can build up an
understanding okay what's the likely
number of people hiding really where are
they more likely to be found and and
from there I can then finally come up
with an answer which might say okay what
you should do for example maybe you want
to change how the queues work or whether
you changing but I would search by this
method about other hood some checks take
longer than others so if you send
everybody through the check that takes a
longer time you get longer long
and that was not acceptable because
eventually Dolores will mr. Fairey so at
what point you tell them to change from
this queue to that queue for example
it's not exactly a mathematical equation
what you do is you do different
scenarios for each scenario get all the
outputs and then from all the outputs
you do a data mining and you might
establish there's some systematic rule
that's going on you might be able to
draw something it goes okay right the
optimum point is here so it's more like
more like a graphical solution one of
the questions you always have with
something like this is are you gonna
check everybody are you gonna check some
people more formally or how you got to
do it with limited resources I mean if
you check everybody for a very long time
then yeah you're gonna find more but the
queues are gonna become ginormous and
nobody's going to catch their flights or
their fairies anymore
so the apt of this really so when you
have limited resources limited time you
need to do your searches selectively and
if you do that we have shown in the
simulation that actually you can find
more people than if you search everybody
for a little bit of time
it got very very political this one you
get so many different stakeholders and
they all want different things I mean
the Port Authority is the one things to
go through as quickly as possible
of course the police want everything to
be checked as carefully as possible the
French want to find people maybe on one
part the British want to find them on
another part it's very political